wieso machen wir das eigentlich nicht
bei amazon sachen einkaufen aus china
und dann 450 formieren reinstellen
vielleicht gibt es ja so einen dummen
gehe ich da das kauft hey leute was
gedacht und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video leute ich hoffe natürlich
geht es gut ich muss direkt am anfang
sagen ich habe sehr lange überlegt ob
ich dieses video überhaupt mache weil es
eigentlich sag ich mal
die kaffeemaschine zu machen ich muss
noch bedanken ich sag mal so weil
eigentlich habe ich dieses produkt an
sich schon mal getestet oder zumindest
die größere variante davon wir haben
jetzt die mini variante anscheinend also
ist wie beim samsung galaxy da gibt es
ja einmal das normale und das mini so
anscheinend auch bei diesem kopfhörer
ich würde sagen wir können uns
eigentlich direkt mal hinsetzen weil ich
muss mich erst mal ein bisschen
aufregend und zwar habe ich mir gedacht
zu meiner airport reihe
ich war ja eine zeit lang oder zwei tage
habe ich halt mal bei dem laden geschaut
bei dem laden wer hat irgendwelche
airport kopien oder irgendwelche ersatz
länger die so ähnlich funktionieren
einfach um die zu testen und dann halt
wieder ein fazit zu ziehen ob das cool
ist ob das sich für euch lohnt zu kaufen
oder nicht und viele von euch haben auch
gesagt anexo doch mal auf amazon da
nicht so viel und ich dachte kann ich
eigentlich noch machen
suchst du dir einfach das produkt raus
was cool aussieht was du noch nicht
getestet hast und was es auch in keinem
anderen laden gibt also irgendwie ein
seriöses produkt eigentlich und ich kann
euch das hier einbinden und so habe ich
dieses produkt gekauft hat eine super
bewertung gab ich habe mich auch gar
nicht zu 100 prozent damit beschäftigen
und gesteht hat 105 rezensionen
viereinhalb sterne kopfhörer bluetooth
kopfhörer für 24 euro 88 habe ich direkt
gekauft wenn ihr auch mal so die bilder
durchgegangen sieht ja eigentlich ganz
cool aus vor allem ihr dieses foto so
und mittlerweile kann ich mich mit dem
ganzen kopien ja auch schon sehr gut aus
und habe für mich festgestellt okay das
ist auf jeden fall kein billig scheiß
den es im internet für 234 euro gibt
habe ich gedacht ich meine 25 euro dafür
sind halt 25 euro wir sollen ja eben was
können ich könnte dazu erst noch viel
mehr sagen wenn ich gar nicht auf jeden
fall sollten danach mittwoch geliefert
werden und am mittwoch kann auch eine
lieferung und ich dachte mir so hey ich
kann es euch mal zeigen
das ist das produkt das angekommen ist
ich habe dann das paket reingeguckt und
dachte mir warte man wo habe ich die
denn jetzt noch mal her und dann ist mir
aufgefallen dass sind die von amazon und
danach ist mir aufgefallen dass ich
ziemlich durch den kakao gezogen wurde
sage ich mal
weil dieses produkt das gibt es auch so
vielen anderen plattformen für 53 und
ich habe dafür 25 euro bezahlt und was
mich da nur so aufregt ich bin ja
wahrscheinlich nicht der einzige der
darauf reingefallen ist und sich das
gekauft hat und viele leute kennen sich
mit sowas ja wahrscheinlich gar nicht
aus und denkt sich ja okay weil sie sich
in ordnung an für 25 euro kann man nicht
meckern das original kostet 180 euro und
dieser typ der diese sachen verkauft und
auch noch das schlimmste ist ja mit
falschen produktfotos darauf hinweist
oder damit wird der verdient sich daran
20 euro gewinn pro produkt und das ist
für mich eine sache die nicht geht
deswegen ist von mir zuerst mal eine
schlechte rezensionen gibt kann ich ja
kurz machen ich habe es euch jemand kurz
rausgesucht ihr könnt ihr hier sehen
genau dieses produkt kann man zum
beispiel auf ebay für drei euro 89
kaufen also noch weniger als die
eigentlich dachte und deswegen habe ich
jetzt auf amazon folgende rezensionen
geschrieben erhalten das produkt weicht
erheblich von den angegebenen
produktbildern sowie vom namen ab das
erhaltene produkt kann man auf
sämtlichen anderen plattformen für drei
euro 89 kaufen zb ebay auf gut deutsch
gesagt eine verarsche wenn sich auch
sehr interessant
ok hat solch einen titel für die
rezension schreiben
ich fühle mich hintergangen und noch ein
ganzes youtube-video mit schlechte
rezensionen gibt's noch ins tor wird da
wird das nie wieder machen aber bevor
ich das volk erst zurückschicke wir
haben es ja hier und ich kann es ja
wenigstens mal testen bereit
ich bin sogar eigentlich sehr gespannt
wir hatten ja letzte woche oder
vorletzte woche habe ich diese dinger
gekauft für 15 euro bei tedi das sind
die normalen i7 tws die gibt es
allerdings auch halt im internet für
fünf euro und tg hat halb zehn drauf
gepackt so habe ich auch schon genug
zugesagt und hier haben wir jetzt im
moment die mini variante davon sieht man
das ja das waren bis jetzt nach dem kick
kopfhörern die schlechtesten und jetzt
stellt sich die frage wie diese hier
sind bei vielleicht könnte ja sein dass
sie ein bisschen was können was ich aber
nicht glaube nur wie gesagt die liegen
jetzt schon rum
das ist nur kurz wieso machen wir das
eigentlich nicht bei amazon sachen
einkaufen aus china und dann 150 fahrer
einstellen
vielleicht gibt es dann darum gehe ich
da das kauft ok
bei den hier ist das ganz komisch wenn
man die korrekten möchte muss man die 1
hörer rausnehmen und dann drückt man
hier auf den knopf und irgendwann fängt
es an zu leuchten
und hier macht man das gleiche und dann
sollten die eigentlich hier erscheinen
einmal kann man hier ist schon verbunden
mit ging ja ganz gut das lustige bei
diesen teilen ist diese bar muschel dies
so riesig die passt fast in mein ohr
weil es so fett ist keine ahnung warum
aber gut machen wir mal ganz kurz machen
wir mal ganz kurz ein zaun test sind die
minister größer als die maxit sehen die
minister größer als die maxis ich glaube
die sind von der pole stimmt das habe
ich gar nicht getestet
die sind eigentlich nur dass man sind
die gleich groß sind die die maxis in
größeren er auch stimmt verdeckte hier
hinten sind
naja so hören wir ein
ich weiß noch bei dem habe ich glaube
ich gesagt das ist unerträglich da
kriegt man kopfschmerzen
deswegen will ich noch ganz kurz noch
einmal hier rein
um das zu vergleichen weil hier war es
gerade absolut in ordnung es war jetzt
kein mega star und aber es war in
ordnung ich muss das noch mal ganz kurz
überprüfen
na ja gut ich also beim letzten machen
wir uns sehr über diese belustigt dass
auch ich noch ich muss sagen ist
eigentlich klingt king beides gleich
also würde ich euch natürlich schon
lieber hier die minis empfiehlt für 389
von ebay
anstatt diese hier einfach weil die
fetzen und ja ich hoffe der amazon hin
da wird so schnell wie möglich aus dem
verkehr gezogen und mehr kann ich in
diesem video gar nicht sagen so ich weiß
dass ich der beste test aber dann will
ich auch gar nicht machen weil es ist
uninteressant das ist jetzt nichts neues
wenn ihr trotzdem noch mal über diese
modelle wissen wollt schaut euch einfach
meint airports video an weil da habe ich
die damals gekauft weil ich euch gleich
am ende und auch in der video
beschreibung ansonsten war es das von
mir
falls sie das sehen her amazon händler
ziehen die ohren lang und ja wir sehen
uns morgen 10 wieder gibt es ein neues
video und hier mache jetzt eine ausnahme
die verlor sie nicht über installieren
da verlose ich sonst immer alles indem
wir einfach um eine zombie antwortete
die schlecht zurück weil die 25 euro
die hole ich mir wieder okay leute das
war's blog aktivieren kann abonnieren